a good trick
with his name is to say toy in the
middle dostoyevsky
he was born in 1821 and grew up on the
outskirts of moscow
his family were comfortably off his
father was a successful doctor
though he happened to work at a
charitable hospital that provided
medical services for the very poor
the family had a house in the hospital
complex so the young dostoevsky was from
the very beginning powerfully exposed to
experiences
from which other children of his
background were usually carefully
sheltered
like almost everyone in cyrus russia his
parents were devout orthodox christians
and dostoyevsky's own religious faith
got deeper and
stronger throughout his life at the age
of 12
he was sent away to school first in
moscow and later in the capital st
petersburg
he got a good education there was a
child of the tiny professional middle
class
he felt out of place among his more
aristocratic classmates
while he was away at school his father
died possibly murdered by his own serfs
after graduating dostoyevsky worked as
an engineer for a while
he started gambling and losing money
something that was to plague him all his
life
in his late twenties he became friends
with a group of radical writers and
intellectuals
he wasn't deeply involved but when the
government decided to crack down on
dissent
dostoyevsky was rounded up to and
sentenced to be shot by a
firing squad however at the last moment
just when the soldiers were ready to
fire a message of reprieve arrived
dostoyevsky was sent instead to siberia
for
four years of forced labor in horrific
conditions
it was only after his return from
siberia that dostoyevsky established
himself as a writer
starting in middle-aged he produced a
series of major books
notes from the underground crime and
punishment the idiot
demons and the brothers karamazov they
are dark
violent and tragic and usually very long
and complicated
he wrote them to preach five important
lessons to the world
incidentally the discussion of
dostoyevsky's ideas does involve
revealing the plots
of some of his novels it's not something
that would have worried him because his
books are written to be read more than
once
but if it bothers you this is the place
to break off
dostoyevsky's first big book notes from
the underground
is an extended rant against life and the
world
delivered by a retired civil servant
this civil servant is deeply
unreasonable
inconsistent and furious with everyone
including himself
he's always getting into arouse he goes
to a reunion of some former colleagues
and tells them all how much he has
always hated them he wants to puncture
everyone's illusions
and make them as unhappy as he is he
seems like a grotesque
character to build a book around but
he's doing something important
he's insisting with a peculiar kind of
intensity on a very strange fact about
the human condition
we want happiness but we have a special
talent
for making ourselves miserable man is
sometimes extraordinarily passionately
in love with suffering that is a fact
he asserts in the novel dostoyevsky is
taking aim at philosophies of progress
and improvement
which were highly popular in his age as
they continue to be
in ours he is attacking our habit of
telling ourselves
that if only this or that thing were
different we could leave suffering
behind
if we got that great job change the
government could afford that great house
invented a machine to fly fast around
the world could get together with or
divorce
from a particular person then all would
go well
this dostoyevsky argues is a delusion
suffering will always pursue us schemes
for improving the world
always contain a flaw they won't
eliminate suffering
they will only change the things that
cause us pain
life can only ever be a process of
changing the focus of pain
never of removing pain itself there will
always be
something to agonize us stop people
starving says dostoyevsky with
calculated wickedness
and you'll soon find there's a new range
of agonies
people will start to suffer from boredom
greed or intense melancholy that they
haven't been invited to the right party
in this spirit notes from the
underground launches an attack on all
ideologies of technical or social
progress
which aspire to the elimination of
suffering they won't succeed
because as soon as they solve one
problem they'll direct our nature to
become unhappy in new ways
dostoyevsky is fascinated by the secret
way in which we actually don't want what
we theoretically seem to seek
he discusses the pleasure a lot of
people get from feelings of superiority
and for whom consequently an egalitarian
society would be a nightmare
or the disavowed but real thrill we get
from hearing about violent crimes on the
news
in which case we'd actually feel
thwarted in a truly peaceful world
notes from the underground is a dark
awkwardly insightful counterpoint
to well-intentioned modern liberalism it
doesn't really show that social
improvement is meaningless
but it does remind us that we'll always
carry our very complex and difficult
selves with us
and that progress will never be as clear
and clean
as we might like to imagine in crime and
punishment
we meet an impoverished intellectual
rodion raskolnikov
though he's currently a nobody he's
fascinated by power and ruthlessness
he thinks of himself as a version of
napoleon
leaders of men such as napoleon were all
without exception
criminals we hear they broke the ancient
laws of their people
to make new ones that suited them better
and they never
feared bloodshed raskolnikov is also
desperate for money
and so aristocratic superiority in mind
he decides to murder an old woman who's
a small-time pawn broker and moneylender
and to steal her cash he's tormented by
the mad injustice of the fact
that this horrible mean old character
has drawers full of rubles
while he who is clever energetic and
profound
is starving he doesn't spend much time
thinking about options like taking a job
as a waiter so raskolnikov breaks into
her apartment and bludgeons her to death
and surprised in the act by the woman's
pregnant half-sister
kills her too but it turns out he's
nothing
like the cold-blooded rational hero of
his own imagination
he is tormented by guilt and horror at
what he has done
eventually he turns himself over to the
police in order to face the proper
punishment for his crime
we're probably never going to do what
raskolnikov did but we often share a
troubling tendency with him
we think we know ourselves better than
we actually do
raskolnikov thinks he's ruthless
actually he's rather tenderhearted
he thinks he won't feel guilt but he's
overwhelmed by remorse
part of our life's journey is to engage
in the tricky task of disentangling
ourselves
from what we think we're like in order
to discover our true nature
raskolnikov is especially fascinating
because of the direction this
self-discovery takes
his striking realization is that he's
actually a much
nicer person than he takes himself to be
whereas so many novelists delight in
showing the sickly reality beneath a
glamorous or enticing facade dostoyevsky
is embarked on a more curious but
rewarding mission
he wants to reveal that beneath the
so-called monster
there can very often be a far more
interesting tenderhearted character
lurking
a nice but deluded intelligent but
frightened
and panicked person sticking for the
moment with crime and punishment it's
very significant the way dostoyevsky
gets us to like his murderous hero
raskolnikov is clearly an attractive
person
at the very start of the book we're told
by the way raskolnikov is
handsome above the average in height
slim well-built
with lovely dark eyes and dark brown
hair dostoevsky
throughout lessens the imaginative
distance between us
who live mainly law abiding and more or
less manageable lives
and them the ones who do terrible things
and wreak havoc with their lives and
those of
others that person he is saying is more
like you
than you might initially want to think
and therefore
more accessible to sympathy the idea
that you can be a good person
do something very bad and still deserve
some compassion
sounds maybe slight and obvious until
one has need of this kind of forgiveness
in one's own life
this is where dostoyevsky wants to enter
our inner conversation with ourselves
and tell us all about his character res
kolnikov a serious
thoughtful good-looking man who did
worse than we have
and still can be compassionately
understood as we can and must all be
this is dostoyevsky's christianity at
work
no one is outside the circle of god's
love and understanding
dostoyevsky's next great book the idiot
takes off from his near-death experience
before the firing squad in the novel he
recounts what that was like
three minutes before his expected death
he is able to see life clearly for the
first time
he notices the gilded spire of a nearby
church
and how it glitters in the sun he'd
never before realized how entrancing a
glint of sunlight could be
he is filled with an immense deep love
of the world
you might see a beggar and think how you
would love to change places with them
so as to be able to continue to breathe
the air and feel the wind
merely to exist seems at that moment of
final revelation
infinitely precious and then the revised
order comes
and it's not over at all what would it
be like to go through one's whole life
in such a state of gratitude and
generosity you wouldn't share
any of the normal attitudes you'd love
everyone equally
you'd be enchanted by the simplest
things you'd never feel angry or
frightened
you would seem to other people to be a
kind of
idiot hence the title of dostoyevsky's
book
it's an extreme version of a very
interesting step we're continually
surrounded by things which could delight
us
if only we saw them in the right way if
only we could learn to appreciate them
dostoyevsky was desperate to communicate
the value of existence
before death would overtake him and us
in dostoyevsky's final great work
brothers karamazov
which came out when he was nearly 60 one
of the central characters tells a long
story within a story it's called the
grand inquisitor
and imagines that the greatest event
looked forward to by christian theology
the second coming of christ has in fact
already happened
jesus did come back several hundred
years ago
he turned up in spain during the highest
period of power in the catholic church
the organization established in theory
at least entirely in devotion to him
christ is back to fulfill his teachings
of forgiveness and universal love
but something rather odd happens the
most powerful religious leader
the grand inquisitor has jesus arrested
and imprisoned
in the middle of the night the grand
inquisitor visits christ in his cell
and explains that he cannot allow him to
do his work on earth
because he is a threat to the stability
of society
christ he says is just too ambitious too
pure
too perfect humanity can't live up to
the impossible goals he sets before us
the fact is people haven't been able to
live according to his teachings
and jesus should admit he failed and
that his ideas of redemption
were essentially misguided the grand
inquisitor
is not really a monster in fact
dostoyevsky portrays him as quite an
admirable figure in the story
he is a guide to a crucial idea that
human beings cannot live in purity
cannot ever be just truly good cannot
live up to christ's message
and that this is something we should
reconcile ourselves to
with grace rather than fury or
self-hatred
we have to accept a great deal of
unreasonableness folly
greed selfishness and short-sightedness
as inner-radicable parts of the human
condition
and plan accordingly and it's not just a
pessimistic thesis about politics or
religion
that we're being introduced to the
primary relevance of this thesis
is as a commentary on our own lives we
won't sort them out
we won't stop being a bit mad and
wayward and we shouldn't torment
ourselves with a dream that we could
if only we tried hard enough become the
perfect beings that idealistic
philosophies like christianity
like to sketch all too readily
dostoyevsky died in 1881
he had a very hard life but he succeeded
in conveying an idea
which perhaps he understood more clearly
than anyone
in a world that's very keen on upbeat
stories we will always run up against
our limitations
as deeply flawed and profoundly muddled
creatures
dostoyevsky's attitude bleak but
compassionate
tragic but kind is needed more than ever
in our naive and sentimental age
that so fervently clings to the idea
which this great russian novelist
loathed that science can save us all and
that we may yet be made perfect through
technology
dostoyevsky guides us to a more humane
darker truth
that as the great sages have always
known life is and ever will be
suffering and yet that there is great
redemption available
in articulating this message in
brilliant and moving
complex and subtle works of art
you